今天覺得天使地利人和
想要來做當中
票好股票之後
準備幹大事
才發現界面寫的是
欸 進線衝
不時心就打開另外一支股票
上面又寫先買衝
這究竟是代表什麼樣的意思呢
想要做當中你必須要搞懂界面上
在寫什麼
然後代表什麼樣的意思
小心別看錯
錢還沒有賺到
就不小心先賠掉了
哈囉 我是魏德
這個頻道主要會用日常的人物
來幫助你了解投資理財
跟自我成長的知識
你如果不想要說過的話
就幫我們按下訂閱吧
因為你的支持是我們創作影片的動力
以買賣線充
以常見的三足系統來舉例
我們進行股票交易界面
點進一支股票之後
會看到畫面的右邊出現
買賣線充
先買充
跟進線充的字樣
只要顯示買賣線充
你就可以做線股當充
也可以做資訊當充
這時候你想要買低賣高的做多
或者是賣高買低的做空都可以
不過你是做資券當中的話
要注意券商的資券數量
能不能夠讓你做融資跟融建
各家券商的數量是不同的
不清楚的話可以連繫你的營業員來了解
這邊跟你補充一個小故事
台股在1985年以前
可以做限股當中的
但因為1985年爆發一件事
震驚全台的實信金融弊案
導致股市重挫
政府為了防止股市繼續下跌
所以停止了限股當中
直到2014年又再重新開放限股當中
2 先買充
你如果看到的是先買充代表你只能做多而不能夠放空
而這邊也只能做限股的做多當充
資券這時候不能當充
因為融資跟融券想要當充做多必須要資買跟券賣
通常是這些股票靠近分配利益
儲權息或股東會的日子
會停止融券
這樣就沒有辦法券賣
在政交所的網站上面可以查到
哪些股票今天只能夠先買充
等於只能做多的情況
台灣也有因為政策規定禁止放空的限空力
如果台股短時間出現了比較大的下跌狀況
金管會他們就會有權利使用限空力來穩定股市
藉由管制借券的數量提高放空的門檻等等的限制
最嚴重的情況就是全面禁止放空
最近一次的限空令是2022年的10月
一直到2023年的2月才解除
三 鏡線充
鏡線充也就是
鏡子做當充
像剛剛上的星櫃
或者是流動性太小的股票
都會被列為鏡線充
這些股票只能夠全額交割
千萬別傻傻的就做下去
然後才發現
欸 怎麼充不掉
不過有些處置股的股票
雖然上面寫字的鏡線充
一樣可以用資訊來做當充
但這並不是每一隻處置股
都可以這麼做
還是得去看APP上面的敘述來做判斷
這邊做個小通診
出現買賣線充
想要做多跟做空都可以
先買充就是只能做多
進線充就是不能夠做當充了
另外做當充的時候
也很常發生一些做空操作的問題
比如說我今天想要做空A股票
可是手上原本就有庫存
那該怎麼辦
點完賣出的時候
這時候一定要把下面出現的賣出線充
勾起來
有些券商的APP版本
會顯示先充賣
但意思都是一樣的
勾了這個之後
系統才會幫你認定你是做空的當充
為了我也會建議
無論你手上有沒有庫存
只要你想做當充做空
下單的時候都可以把這個給勾起來
如果還是不清楚自己的下單見面
建議一定要找你的營業員來了解
才不會下作單造成了這些虧損
把當充的下單見面弄懂的時候
心動的你是不是想要進場要幹大事
但當充的讓很大
新聞都寫得很可怕
但又想要來跟著獲利
所以又擔心自己賠光了存款
那哪一些訊號是可以進場
要怎麼樣來判斷
這是不是一個獲利的機會
欸 別擔心
為了呢
為了為你準備好了
清楚又好懂的投資教學
而且他是免費的
就把這這邊和你介紹一位施戰派的老師
老師會根據他多年的實證經驗
透過步驟化的一步一步的高生育全股方法
來達到每年過曆百萬以上
老師會從基本面
技術面跟籌碼面來教你
如何主動並有效率的找到有潛力的強勢股
與其花費包括的時間
跟金錢自己去摸索
直接跟有結果的人學習
跟拿方法最有效率
這可以幫助我們少走萬路
學習正確的投資技巧
而我們也希望透過這樣子的一個教學
來幫助你跟大家
克服投資上面所遇到的困難和障礙
給自己一個機會也給我們一個機會
現在就點選下方的資訊欄裡面的
第一個連結吧
最後我們來複習一下今天所學到的知識
關於當充下單界面
哪一個敘述是錯的
1 買賣現充就代表這支股票
可以做多也可以做空
2 進現充就代表沒有辦法做限股當充
3 手上有庫存又想要當充做空
要勾選賣出現充
4 股票出現的先買充
還是可以限股做空
搬個答案寫在留言處
這能夠幫助你消化今天的影片內容喔
或者你有任何投資的相關問題
也歡迎你在我們底下留言跟提問
如果你今天已經看到這邊的話
代表今天的影片內容
應該也對你有所幫助吧
我們會繼續製作更多有關投資理財
跟自我成長的相關知識
幫我們按個讚跟訂閱
是對我們影片的支持
你如果想要收到我們新片上載通知
一定要開信的小鈴鐺才不會錯過
確保有祝福你在投資的大陸上
獲利滿滿帶到財富自由
我是魏德
我們下個影片見啦
掰掰